IT’S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE"."
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN
ACQUITTED, BUT THE FIGHT OVER
IMPEACHMENT APPEARS FAR FROM
OVER.
A TRIUMPHANT TRUMP TAKING A
MAJOR VICTORY LAP OF THE
NATIONAL PRAYER BREAKFAST THIS
MORNING, HOLDING UP AND
ACQUITTED NEWSPAPER HEADLINE AND
ATTACKING HIS POLITICAL FOES.
>> I DON’T LIKE PEOPLE WHO USE
THEIR FAITH AS JUSTIFICATION FOR
DOING WHAT THEY KNOW IS WRONG,
NOR DO I LIKE PEOPLE WHO SAY I
PRAY FOR YOU.
WHEN THEY KNOW THAT THAT’S NOT
SO.
>> Dana: NANCY PELOSI
RESPONDED WITH THESE HARSH
WORDS.
>> I PRAY HARD FOR HIM BECAUSE
HE IS SO OFF THE TRACK OF OUR
CONSTITUTION, OUR VALUES, OUR
COUNTRY.
HE’S TALKING ABOUT THINGS THAT
HE KNOWS LITTLE ABOUT.
FAITH AND PRAYER.
HE IS IMPEACHED FOREVER, NO
MATTER WHAT HE SAYS WHAT
HEADLINES HE WANTS TO CARRY
AROUND.
>> Dana: POLICE PELOSI TAKING DI
AIM AT THE STATE OF THE UNION.
>> THE PRESIDENT USING THE
CONGRESS OF THE UNITED STATES AS
A BACKDROP FOR A REALITY SHOW.
I TORE UP A MANIFESTO OF
MISTRUTHS AND I DON’T NEED ANY
LESSONS FROM ANYBODY, ESPECIALLY
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, ABOUT DIGNITY.
NEXT YEAR WE WILL HAVE A NEW
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
IT’S AN ABSOLUTE IMPERATIVE.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT GOING
OFF ON PELOSI COME IMPEACHMENT
AND MUCH MORE.
>> WERE TREATED UNBELIEVABLY
UNFAIRLY.
WE FIRST WENT THROUGH RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
IT WAS ALL [BLEEP]
ADAM SCHIFF IS A VICIOUS,
HORRIBLE PERSON.
NANCY PELOSI IS A HORRIBLE
PERSON.
SHE WANTED TO IMPEACH A LONG
TIME AGO AND SHE SAID I.
PRAY FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
SHE DOESN’T PRAY.
SHE MAY PRAY BUT SHE PRAYS FOR
THE OPPOSITE.
THEY BROUGHT ME TO THE FINAL
STAGES OF IMPEACHMENT.
BUT NOW WE HAVE THAT GORGEOUS
WORD.
I NEVER THOUGHT A WORD WITH
SOUND SO GOOD.
IT’S CALLED TOTAL ACQUITTAL.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, EMILY.
TOTAL ACQUITTAL.
>> Emily: I’M LAUGHING BECAUSE
HE SAID IT WAS ONE WORD AND IT
WAS TOO.
I THINK WHAT RESONATED SO
STRONGLY WITH ME WAS THE SMALL
WORLD PELOSI IS LIVING IN.
SHE DOESN’T SEE THAT THIS ENTIRE
TIME WHAT IS RESONATED FOR THE
PRESIDENT IS THAT THE ENTIRE
TIME HE HAS ALIGNED HIMSELF WITH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE’S NEVER BADMOUTH OR CRITICIZE
THE PUBLIC OR AN ENTIRE SEGMENT
OF THE POPULATION, WHICH IS WHY
THE DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO SHOOT
THEMSELVES IN THE FOOT AND SEEMS
SO OUT OF TOUCH.
IT’S ALSO WHY THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TOOK SUCH OFFENSE AT HER
RIPPING UP THAT SPEECH BECAUSE
IT WAS RIPPING UP THEM.
HE WAS RIPPING UP NAMES AND
POLICIES AND A FEELING OF BEING
HEARD THIS PRESIDENT HAS DONE
THIS ENTIRE TIME.
WE’VE SAT THROUGH TWO YEARS OF
MUELLER AND SIX MONTHS OF
IMPEACHMENT AND THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE TRIED TO TELL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHAT THEY SAID HE DID.
NO ONE WANTS TO GO OFF THAT
LEDGE ANYMORE.
WE HAVE BEEN SOLD A BOMBSHELL
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
WHO WANTS TO TAKE ANOTHER LEAP
OF FAITH.
EVERYONE IS EXHAUSTED.
TO SEE HER PERPETUATING THAT
SAME CELL FLY IN THAT SAME ECHO
CHAMBER, THERE’S NOTHING TO SHOW
FOR IT EXCEPT OUR FATIGUE AND
THE FACT THAT SHE’S KNOCKING TO
BE SPEAKER NEXT TIME AROUND.
>> Dana: SHE IS HAVING WHAT
YOU WOULD CALL A NO-GOOD, VERY
BAD WEEK.
>> Greg: I HAVE ADVICE FOR
THESE PEOPLE.
IF YOU WANT TO GET TRUMP OUT OF
THE WHITE HOUSE, HERE IS AN EASY
STRATEGY.
WAIT FIVE YEARS.
THAT’S ALL YOU HAVE TO DO.
I KNOW PEOPLE ARE UPSET ABOUT
THE PRESS OR.
I WOULD’VE BEEN WORSE.
THREE YEARS.
>> Dana: THERE’S NO DOUBT.
>> Greg: AT LEAST HE THANKED
EVERYBODY.
I WOULD BE SCREAMING MY HEAD --
I WOULD BE USING MUCH WORSE
LANGUAGE.
I THOUGHT THAT THE PRESSER WAS
HILARIOUS, IT WAS GREAT.
HE WAS RIGHT.
THERE WILL BE PEOPLE LIKE JUAN
WHO DISAGREE COMPLETELY.
BECAUSE ONE SIDE THAT FEELS
REALLY BAD ABOUT THIS IN ONE
SIDE THAT’S ECSTATIC.
WE CAN AGREE THAT BOTH SIDES
LOOKING AT THE SAME THING AND
SEEING TWO DIFFERENT THINGS,
RIGHT?
SO WHAT’S THE ANSWER?
WHICH SIDE IS BEST AT PREDICTING
THE OUTCOMES?
WHEN YOU HAVE THESE TWO
DIFFERENT VISIONS, WHAT
PREDICTED THE IMPLOSION OF
COLLUSION OR THE OBSTRUCTION OR
KAVANAUGH COME IMPEACHMENT?
IT’S THE PEOPLE THAT WERE HAPPY
TODAY.
THAT SIDE HAS BEEN ABLE TO
PREDICT WITH ALMOST 100%
CERTAINTY WHAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THE OTHER SIDE WAS SO
EMOTIONALLY DAMAGED, DAMAGED
BECAUSE EVERY TIME THEIR SIDE IS
WRONG BECAUSE OF THEIR COGNITIVE
DISSONANCE, THEY CANNOT
UNDERSTAND WHY THE VISION IN
THEIR HEAD ISN’T MATCHING THE
REALITY OUTSIDE.
NANCY DID NOT LOOK -- SHE LOOKED
LIKE SHE HAD HAD IT, I THINK THE
REASONS THAT HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH TRUMP.
HER OWN SITE HAS NOT HELPED HER.
EVERY TIME THEY PREDICT
SOMETHING IT’S BAD AND IT BLEEDS
INTO IOWA.
THEY GET EVERYTHING WRONG.
>> Dana: JANUARY WAS LIKE
IRAN, IMPEACHMENT.
THEN THEY HAVE IOWA.
IT IS LIKE THE IDES OF FEBRUARY.
>> Juan: I COULDN’T BELIEVE
WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID IN THE
EAST ROOM.
WE JUST PLAYED HIM USING
PROFANITY.
I DON’T THINK IT’S ME WHEN I SEE
A PRESIDENT BEHAVE LIKE THAT.
I THINK THIS IS INAPPROPRIATE
AND WRONG.
I THINK MOST AMERICANS, BY THE
WAY, WOULD AGREE WITH ME.
I DON’T THINK THAT HE’S IN TOUCH
WITH AMERICANS.
I THINK HE DID A POWER PLAY AND
THERE WERE A LOT OF SPINELESS
REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE WHO
JUST COULDN’T DEAL WITH A MATTER
OF CONSCIENCE.
WHEN IT COMES TO RELIGION, WHICH
WAS SO CENTRAL, BY THE WAY, IN
THE WAY THAT MITT ROMNEY --
HANG ON.
WHAT MADE ROMNEY DID AND WHAT
NANCY PELOSI DID WOULD SAY THIS
IS APPALLING BEHAVIOR.
THEY THEREFORE ACTED IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THEIR CONSCIENCE
AND THEIR FAITH, IS WHAT
MITT ROMNEY SAID.
>> Greg: IT’S CONVENIENT.
>> Juan: AND THEN THE
PRESIDENT SPEAKS TO THIS
RELIGION ANGLE TODAY, DANA.
BUT OF COURSE HE BEHAVED
INAPPROPRIATELY AT THE PRAYER
BREAKFAST.
THIS GUY --
>> Lawrence: WHEN HE SAID SHE
WAS SEDATED.
>> Juan: THIS GUY DOESN’T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT RELIGION.
HE DOESN’T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
FORGIVENESS COME ABOUT HUMILITY.
HE DOESN’T.
HE DOESN’T LIVE HIS LIFE THAT
WAY.
HE SAID HE DOESN’T FORGIVE
PEOPLE.
GREG, YOU SAID DON’T JUDGE
WORDS, JUDGE BY ACTIONS.
LOOK AT HIS ACTIONS.
>> Greg: AND HE’S ACQUITTED.
IT’S A GREAT ACTION.
>> Juan: THIS IS NOT A
CHRISTIAN LIFE.
>> Lawrence: FOR YEARS WE’VE
HEARD THE DEMOCRATS SAY THAT
NANCY PELOSI WAS THE ADULT IN
THE ROOM.
SHE DOESN’T DO NAME-CALLING.
SHE CALLED THE PRESIDENT SEDATED
TODAY.
SHE’S CLASSY, AND IN THE HOUSE
SHE RIPPED UP HIS SPEECH.
THE DEMOCRATS CAN NO LONGER
CLAIM THEY HAVE THE MORAL HIGH
GROUND.
WHAT I’VE BEEN TELLING PEOPLE
FOR YEARS IS THAT THE WAY TRUMP
BEHAVES IS MUCH LIKE MANY OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE HOUSE.
THEY JUST DO IT BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS.
THE DIFFERENCE WITH TRUMP IS, HE
IS WHO HE IS AND THIS WAS A DAY
OF CELEBRATION BECAUSE NOT ONLY
WAS IT ABOUT HIM.
THEY DESTROYED THIS MAN’S
FAMILY, WENT AFTER EVERYONE IN
THE CABINET, EVERY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATE.
THEY USED POLITICAL PRESSURE IN
THE PROSECUTION TO SQUEEZE
PEOPLE ON FALSE CHARGES THAT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH COLLUSION.
THEY DESTROYED EVERYONE THAT WAS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PRESIDENT.
>> Juan: SO HE GETS AWAY WITH
LYING?
HE LIES IN THE STATE OF THE
UNION, OUTRIGHT LIES ABOUT
HEALTH CARE.
OH, I AM PROTECTING PEOPLE WITH
PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS.
>> Lawrence: REPUBLICANS STOOD W
DEMOCRATS ON PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS.
YOU DIDN’T WANT TO STAND FOR
SCHOOL CHOICE, THE TUSKEGEE
AIRMEN.
>> Juan: YOU KNOW WHAT I LIKED
ABOUT THAT SPEECH, THE STATE OF
THE UNION, IT WAS REALITY TV
WITH A TV PERFORMANCE BUT IT WAS
INSULTING TO THE HOUSE BECAUSE
YOU DON’T GIVE RUSH LIMBAUGH A
MEDAL OF FREEDOM.
THE FIRST LADY PUT IT.
IT WAS LIKE A SIDESHOW.
>> Lawrence: DEMOCRATS SHOULD
RETHINK THEIR STRATEGY AS THE
PRESIDENT IS RISING IN APPROVAL.
HIS APPROVAL RATING IS GOING UP.